Property prices across the country have grown 22 percent in a year.
Hobart had the biggest annual growth, followed by Sydney and Brisbane,...
...and values in the regions have outpaced those in capital cities.
Annual appreciation in housing values that we've seen...
...is the highest 12-month growth rate since 1989,...
...and rental values have also grown since their highest levels since the early 2000s,...
...so sitting about 9 percent higher.
The pace of growth in the housing market is slowing...
...due to rising mortgage rates, stricter lending rules...
...and more properties up for sale.
But, the big banks are still tipping price rises of between 6 and 8 percent in 2022...
...before values drop in 2023.
CBA is forecasting the steepest fall of 10 percent.
Some analysts warn that if new COVID variants caused lengthy lockdowns,...
...house prices could continue to grow in the double digits.
As the gap between housing and unit values grows to nearly 38 percent,...
...2022 is set to see high-density living become more appealing...
...because it's more affordable.